- On this episode we tackle
is Reddit sold out already?
Embedded Facebook videos on your website.
And how do I build a digital team
inside of my print and TV agency?
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hi everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 87
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Before I get into the show, I want to give
a huge shout out to all the
VaynerNation that's watching
live on Meerkat right
now and who jumped in
and gave a little sharey
share share to the video
I just put out on Facebook.
We can link it in the comments on YouTube.
We can't put it up here
because it has to be
on GaryVaynerchuk.com.
Correct?
Correct.
But linked in the YouTube I
know a lot of podcast listeners
are listening so if you jump in and you go
to Facebook.com/Gary
a video I just put up
a little bit ago an original
video we've been making
these videos DRock, Staphon,
the whole video team
has been crushing for me.
I'm really proud of this
one it speaks to my essence.
The inception music is exciting
and most of all I just am really grateful
for the Vayniacs, the VaynerNation
that just did that for me.
Big share up, a little
right hook on Meerkat before
the show so thank you.
And now let's get into the show.
As we get into the show
first I want to show Stunwin
who you know has been a
rare appearance lately.
It's been very, very, very
much the India show here.
But it's good to have you
in the house Mr. Stunwin.
- Taking it back to our roots.
- Roots baby roots.
- Alright--
- You sound like Eric Kastner
when Mott became a celebrity.
(laughs)
On Wine Library TV that's
for you old school Vayniacs.
Alright I like Crush It! up here too.
Let's get the show on I'm lollygagging.
- Lewis asks "Where would
you start in building
a digital team within a
traditional TV or print agency?"
- Lewis there's an interesting
thing that I believe in very
much which is you are what
your actions show you are.
It's very similar, I'm probably
affected by Bill Parcells,
in football legendary hall
of famer coach Bill Parcells
former Jet coach always said
you are what your record
says you are because everyone's
like we're eight and eight
but we could have been 10
and six if we you know,
but at the end of the
day you are what you are.
Thanks Mike.
It's very easy to create
a digital practice within
a traditional print or direct
mail, outdoor media or PR.
All these agencies now have
to shift into the world
that we've created because
that's where the dollars
and the momentum and where
the story telling is going.
This video will be consumed
a hell of a lot more
in YouTube and Facebook
native than it will
as a pre roll pop up somewhere.
And so I think it's super
important that you understand
you are what your actions say you are.
Meaning it's very easy, go out
and hire seven to 12 people
that work in digital social,
bring them into your department
and now you have that capability.
Now the key for the CEO or
the chairman of the board,
her and his job is to
really integrate that new,
we're going through it now
VaynerMedia has a new live
division called VaynerLive,
it's live events activation.
It's not what we've historically done.
It's activating at Coachella or South By
or things of that nature.
And we're six months in and
we still have to integrate it
into the business but we brought in Robert
and other people that have
done that work in the past.
Now we have the skill set.
Now how does that practice mold in
to the whole organization?
That's the tricky part, that's
where dictatorship comes in.
That's where letting things happen
the way they have to happen.
I'm a big fan of letting things
lie so I've stayed hands-off
for the first several
six and a half months.
Now maybe I feel like maybe
like I'll get my hands
in a little bit dirtier
just get it molded in.
Leadership is knowing when to
listen, knowing when to talk.
Knowing when to take a
step back, knowing when
to jump in and integrate it.
But the commodity of
hiring people that have
the skill set to do the
work, it's out there.
It's just making the
leap to decide to do it.
- Andrew asks "Do you plan
on embedding Facebook videos
on your website instead of
YouTube videos, and is it more
beneficial to do so if
you're not monetizing?"
- Andrew I'm a big fan of Facebook video,
hence the whole rant here early on.
We put it up on YouTube
and I clearly just threw my
right hook to Facebook.
Funny thing about me is,
my actions always speak
to where my strategy is.
That's an interesting
insight I care less about
the perception of having 20,
50, 100,000 views on Youtube
than I do about getting
the Facebook virality that
that ecosystem creates.
I'm a big fan of it because
the truth is the virality
that Facebook allows you is
greater than the virality
that YouTube allows you.
And I think when you're
not monetizing virality,
the ability for it to get
shared and new people to see it,
the VaynerNation just
helped me so much and I asked
for even more, I want people
to see this because I believe
it's a good piece of content
for me to be a first look at me
because it's really an
essence of who I am.
It's a good first look, it's a
good first impression for me.
It's also very well produced.
I'm interested in people seeing it.
And right now, Facebook
feels like the right place
to send those people so yes,
I would be and I recommend
and I think you should,
everybody should be very serious
about embedding Facebook
videos into their pages
in lieu of YouTube at least
for nothing else than context.
You may want to go back to
YouTube for whatever rationale
because it's a very important
and very powerful platform
as well you may be going into
the new subscription product
they have maybe a million
different things and reasons
to do it but here's
what I don't understand.
You know what you're getting
from Youtube from last decade.
By not tasting what Facebook
could be bringing to you
is just a mistake in overall strategy.
- Hi Gary Lori Greiner
here from "Shark Tank."
I always say I can tell
instantly if something is a hero
or a zero but I'm in the wine
section here and I can't tell
what is the difference
between any of these wines.
Help me.
- Lori, first of all thank
you so much for the question.
Big shout out to all the
sharks that I've been,
mingling with the sharks lately.
Look Lori, I think
everybody has this problem.
I think that buying wine when
you're trying to figure it out
you're not going to be able to
make a judgment on the label.
Buying wine based on the
label crushes my soul.
Buying wine because the
shelf talker says 90 points
is the secondary move
that crushes my soul,
though Wine Library does
that at scale we put
up those shelf talkers
'cause it sells wine.
I think the best thing you
can do is form a relationship
with your wine person and have them
really learn your palate over time.
That's gonna work for you
70, 80% of time 'cause you're
not always gonna be by your
local wine shop or that person
might be sick that day, duh duh duh duh.
I think the best move in
lieu of the wine person is
to try a different
varietal every time you go.
By recognizing that trying a
gewurtztraminer or a marson
or a russon or a lirac,
or a (mumbles) or a lagrein, cornas.
Trying these different things, (mumbles)
trying new stuff is
always a great way to go.
You're scared that you're gonna
try something you don't like
but again it's really no
different than the advice
I just gave about Facebook video.
When you haven't tried
something you can't judge it.
Got it?
The value of trying something
and creating the context,
content is king, context is
god something I love to say.
This is another version of it.
You got to try new stuff so,
build a relationship.
Steve you know my pal
at whaddayou got today?
Oh weird you're recommending a pinotage
from South Africa cool I'll try it.
But no Steve, he's sick today?
Try something, oh I've never
had anything from Lodi before.
Or I've disregarded buttery
chardonnays for five years.
Let me try another one just
to see where my palate is
and where those chards are
in California these days.
So mix it up.
- I wouldn't recommend you a pinotage.
It would be very unlikely.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Rodolfo asks
"Do you have a business card?
If so can we see it?"
- Rodolfo I do not have a business card.
A business card in 2015
makes absolutely zero sense.
A business card delivers information.
Take out your (beep) phone and
email the person on the spot.
Better, cleaner, never
lose the business card.
More efficient, it's
right I like to show them,
is this your email?
Good, good, good.
Like pchtaw.
(laughing)
- Alex asks "Will Reddit be
ruined by future marketers?
If so, how?"
- Alex everything gets ruined by marketers
because marketers want to make money.
Original audiences feel it's ruined.
Will Reddit be ruined by marketers?
That's like asking when
you're indie band becomes big,
did they sell out?
Some say yes some say no.
It's really eyes of the beholder.
I'm sure there's people,
Steve you love Reddit.
Go to Steve, let's go to Steve.
- I do.
- There's clearly more it's
more commercial than it was
seven or eight years ago--
- There's people who say
it's already been ruined.
- Thank you where do you sit on that?
- I don't think so at all.
- Okay but you feel like people
that are even more cynical
and extreme than you--
- Exist--
- have gone there.
- Yes.
- And so that's it.
I'm optimist dah, dah,
dah, commerce salesman.
Steve is more cynical, more down the line
creating friction and there's
people that are completely
out of their goddamn mind
that the second Reddit makes
one cent that in itself
signifies that it sold out.
By the way I respect that
because I'm the extreme.
I look at everything until it makes money.
I'm like that's sold out,
the other way, right?
That's too pure.
I think that it's eye of the beholder.
I think Facebook is less sold out today
than it was 26 months ago.
Because I think their algorithm's
better, think about that.
26 months later and that's
an arbitrary number,
24, 20 you know, I don't even
know how I came up with that.
26 months later Facebook is
doing a better job putting
stuff in people's feed that
makes it feel less commercial
than it did before because the
algorithm is getting better.
To me that's wild, that's wi--
I mean it's better for me.
Taking like personal me, it's crazy to me.
They've done a good job, so ebb and flow.
Reddit may do a takeover
thing next week with Taco Bell.
All of a sudden Steve will
be like arghhh I was wrong.
One week later it's sold
out, it's just ebb and flows.
Marketers and business
people's jobs are to make money
that will always go against
the friction of people
that want to keep things
artistic and pure.
It's a good friction
point I think the people
that are really special at
it can walk the Mendoza line.
You think of an Apple,
you think of a Nike,
you think of a Reddit.
I'm fascinated by that.
It's something I try to keep
and I think I skew a little bit
more towards commerce
and sell out than I do
than artists but that's because
I talk about the subject
matter of business that I
think one of the reasons
I'm lucky enough to have an audience is
I'm in the jabs business.
You know the right hooks
are coming and as long as
I'm providing way more
jabs than right hooks,
the balance of the force,
Chewbacca style, is in good shape.
That's the scoop, that's the show.
Question of the day is a right hook.
I want you to watch this goddamn video
and then I want you to
leave a comment on it.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Hey everyone so here is
the Meerkat right hook.
I just posted this video and I tweeted it.
So I just posted it on my Facebook page.
Let's make sure that it's up there.
Just want to go facebook.com/gary
yes there it is.
You're seeing it all right.
And I just tweeted it Casey
Neistat gave me some love on it.
I'm sorry nice you saw that?
- No not yet.
- Yeah just gave me some love.
Yeah so it's on Twitter, it's on Facebook.
What I wanna understand is,
is the VaynerNation willing
to, right now, go to the video
and hit the share button?
Right 'cause that's
really interesting to me.
Right now it's at 49 'cause I
wanna create instant virality,
little right hook action,
little gameification Meerkat action here.
So we're at 53 who is willing
to give me a yes or no,
who is willing to go and
give me a share right now
on the Facebook video, who's in?
Who's in?
I'm gonna have to now wait.
(laughing)
And wait.
Oh here we go, yes, absolutely,
Shawn thank you so much.
Video feed down what is he saying?
Oh the video feed is down?
My video feed on Meerkat?
I don't think so.
- It sometimes it is (mumbles)
- My wifi's on I'm good.
Yes, yes, yes.
Hang on I'm gonna go do it.
Thank you so much Cody,
thank you so much Keith.
Thank you so much ughh, Brad
Perry thank you so much.
Too late I already did it thank you, done,
Oh this is gonna be fun to watch.
Let's watch this together, 62.
You got a 62 let me get my refresh.
This is fun.
I got 67.
- There she goes 100.
- 71--
- On a 100.
- I got 72 (laughing)
DRock club's a 100 I called
him Dave because I got excited.
(laughing) 76.
VaynerNation thank you so much.
(mumbles) Oh yeah it is
a fresh cut thank you.
It would mean so much to
me if you guys can pass
on this video I think who did this?
You, Staphon, who did it?
You did it DRock?
So (mumbles) you're always
working together duh, duh, duh.
But I thought this was a really good one.
I'm really personally
excited about this one
'cause it's one of the first times ever
ever my dad is starring in it.
(mumbles) 97.
(background chatter)
Yay 100 yay!
I want to show them that my dad's in this.
There he is.
Sasha, Brandon, John K.
It's good.
- [Voiceover] The fact that
I've been working 19 hours a day
every day for the last 20 years
is easy for me it's the only
- Thank you guys so much, 'preciate it.
Right let's get on to the show.
I'll give you a follow on the
'Gram, hit me up on Twitter.
If you want me to do things
hitting me up on Twitter's
usually a really good way to go about it.
Cool I appreciate it, I
appreciate you absorbing my
right hook VaynerNation
and honestly this video
means a lot to me so anything
you can do, the share
is huge but whether it's
Twitter or email, newsletter,
or blog posts I want to get
this out there to the link
to the Facebook means a lot to me.
I'm curious by the virality
of the share units.
So thank you so much.
Alright now give it to you
Staphon let's get into the show.
Where's India?
- She's ill--
Not feeling well?
I'm just taking one more look 127.
So fun what's the update on the shares?
- We're at 197 shares.
- [Staphon] Woah.
- Let's go VaynerNation, get
everybody in, get on g-chat.
Text friends, let's go (laughing)
Where's Tyler let's go!